- If you're parented well, you
can see if from a mile away,
and when you're not you
can see it from a mile away
and I think too many parents
view their kids as a product.
We need to do a much
better job, zero to 18
to understand somebody's makeup,
their emotional makeup, their skill set.
The way we do school today
and the way we structure
our kids for success
in the first 18 years
is so broken, worldwide.
For a lot of parent, their kid
is a representation of them,
and that's where it breaks.
It breaks if a parent thinks
that a kids accomplishment
is a reflection them, because
now you have a disconnect.
Now you're not a parent and a child,
you're a person with a product
and I think, that, that is scary to me,
because going to Harvard,
or Stanford, or Yale,
is a badge that people back in Beijing
walk around proudly to
their contemporaries
and they're fuckin' their kids up.
If you look at America as a proxy,
when the middle class started to emerge
it was also when University and college
was starting to build as a brand
and it worked for a period
of time, that was fine,
but the problem is technology
is to much of a variable.
If you want your kids to be successful,
recognize that the world you live in today
has nothing to do with the
world their gonna live in.
- That's so true.
- I had parents who had
those same pressures,
who came from those same places,
who refuse to treat me that way,
and that's why I'm gonna be special.
I want that for the gadrillions
of kids around the world,
because they deserve it.
The fact that 99 out of 100
parents back in Chinese New Year
put unneeded pressure on their kids,
which ultimately is going
to hurt their children
and hurt their relationship
with their children
is, needs to start being eradicated
- One things happening.
- Please.
- In China that is an optimism,
it's very optimistic point of view
is the government is now
encouraging graduates
to take entrepreneurship
as their first job.
- I think it's great
that it's pushing kids
to entrepreneurship.
My problem is, nine out of
10 of these Chinese kids
that are 22 years olds,
that are jumping into
entrepreneurship have no chance,
'cause they're not entrepreneurs.
- Yes, but it's good,
because it's education.
- Yes, but you have to be careful
because the one thing I fear,
is when theses kids fail
and almost all of them will,
it's a very big scarlet
letter in that culture,
and I think psychologically,
you're putting a 23 year old
in a very vulnerable spot
where now they have a loss,
publicly, there's no hiding.
When you lose in school like
I did, you can blame people.
When Iris loses at Vayner
Media she can blame me.
When you work at a company,
or when the governments
involved, or when it's school,
you can blame somebody else.
When you have a business, it's your fault.
So I would caution one thing
for anybody who's listening
who thinks entrepreneurship
is such a freedom.
When you lose, you have to make sure
that you're mentally stable enough
to be able to take all that cynicism
and the critiques from everybody,
including your friends, your
friends parents, your parents,
because if you don't you start going down
a very dangerous path that
leads to a very scary place.
We do not reconcile why
we have suicide in America
at the teenage level.
It's because modern parenting
is over coddling kids to an extreme level
where kids don't know how
to deal with adversity.
I think self awareness matters much more
than being an entrepreneur.
For you and I the learning
makes sense, it's our DNA.
I look at every loss as learning.
That is not how people are wired.
We need to do a much
better job zero to 18,
to understand somebody's makeup.
- To go deeper there
are a lot of new family,
they just newly became the middle class.
So the middle class is booming.
So they're afraid that their gonna lose,
because they just got there.
The only way that they can
think of to maintain this status
is to invest in their kids education,
or push a little bit harder to make sure
their kids can carry on the status.
- [Gary] I get it.
So that's one pressure.
- Their wrong.
I understand, their gonna lose.
What they don't understand
is how quickly the world is evolving
and how we're all more connected than ever
and we're all looking
at each others cultures.
I think the greatest thing
that is ever gonna happen to
America is China's emergence.
I think kids that are gonna
be born 10 years from now
are gonna be winners in
America 40 years from now,
because of the chip on their shoulder
of loosing that world stage leadership.
- So what should parents
invest in their kids,
like what aspect?
- One thing I would tell parents,
is do a lot more listening
and don't listen to your fuckin' friends.
(laughing and clapping)
Listen to your kids, and
when I say listening,
watch them, what do
they gravitate towards?
Nobody thought playing
video games 20 years ago
was gonna lead to a
luxurious financial life.
It clearly has.
(soft music)